[Music]
[Music]
why are you trying to take me out
Deadshot maybe I just like being around
you
now nobody it's a freebie I can make you
tell me the truth girl fine we'll do it
the easy way
now tell me who laughs I know what are
you doing where's the lasso of truth
[Music]
thanks for skinning it buddy
willows never gonna know whoa whoa Wow
there you are I'm busy here booster tell
me what you're up to
I stole the lasso of truth and made
plastic man take its place while they
used it to make sure I'm getting a good
deal on my new booster car because I
accidentally parked the last one in the
junkyard now I can't find it because I'm
terrible at caring for the things I love
and one time in second grade I ate a
whole glob of paste when no one was
looking at my time soon it hasn't worked
for a few months but I haven't told
anybody I just keep pretending I'm
traveling in time but really I'm just
traveling to ice cream shops eating ice
cream sundaes I'm wishing it was based
wow this thing really does work yes it
does lex luthor and we're done here that
was great I feel amazing I love ice
cream chocolate chocolate chip two
scoops
you'll get nothing and you'll like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]